-Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Enjoy yourself, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching at home.
Well, guys, last night
here on NBC
was the third Republican
presidential debate,
and it's being described
as "unhinged."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
There was name-calling,
wild rants,
and personal attacks.
Even Trump was watching
like, "Game recognizes game."
[ Laughter ]
"Game recognize game!"
Yeah, it was vicious.
At one point,
Lester Holt was like,
"We interrupt this debate
with a 'Real Housewives' reunion
already in progress."
[ Laughter ]
It was quite a night.
During the two-hour debate,
Nikki Haley got
the most questions,
Tim Scott spoke the longest,
and Ron DeSantis spoke
the [coughs] shortest.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, one of the big moments
from the night
was when Vivek Ramaswamy went
after Nikki Haley's daughter
for being on TikTok.
Watch this.
-I want to laugh
at why Nikki Haley
didn't answer your question,
which is about looking
at families in the eye.
In the last debate,
she made fun of me
for actually joining TikTok
while her own daughter
was actually using the app
for a long time.
So you might want to take care
of your family first.
-Leave my daughter out
of your voice.
-Adult daughter.
The next generation
of Americans are using it.
Here's the truth.
-You're just scum.
-The easy answer...
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Ooh.
-Then the moderator tried
to calm things down,
and he was like,
"Nikki, Vivek, remember,
none of you
are going to be president."
[ Laughter ]
"Just want to --
Just calm it down."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Calm down."
Not only did the attack
backfire for Vivek,
it also went viral on TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
And get this.
For a while now,
Tim Scott has claimed
to have a girlfriend,
but no one has ever seen her,
and donors have been worried
it's hurting him in the race.
So, after the debate,
he brought her up on stage.
Yeah. When asked how they met,
she was like,
"I was his Uber driver
on the way over here."
[ Laughter ]
Smart move by Tim Scott.
He's probably not
gonna be president,
but at least people know
that he has a fake girlfriend.
So that's good.
[ Laughter ]
"She lives in Canada.
You guys don't know her."
[ Laughter ]
"She doesn't go to school here."
Meanwhile, former president
Trump didn't attend the debate
and said held his own rally
just a few miles away.
It was the first time
a Trump rally
was the less chaotic
Republican event.
During the rally,
Trump said Republicans
should stop wasting time
on debates.
Then he said, "And let's also
stop wasting time on elections
and just declare me
the winner, okay?
Come on."
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears, you guys,
here's some great news.
After 118 days,
the Screen Actors Guild
reached a deal with
the Hollywood studios.
The strike is over!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, tune in tomorrow
when my guests will be everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, yes, interesting that the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
Whoa.
The guys from
Please Don't Destroy.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
What are you guys doing here?
Shouldn't you be up at "SNL"?
-Dude, I'll tell you
what we're doing here.
-What?
-We were on the show
three days ago,
and we couldn't talk about
our movie
'cause of the actors strike.
-Yeah, but now it's over,
and we can talk about it.
So why don't you book us?
-What do you mean,
why don't we book you?
You were just here.
-Yeah, but we weren't able
to talk about our movie.
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
coming out on Peacock.
-Yeah, well...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, you come back,
and you can talk about it.
-Who do you have booked tonight?
-We're fully booked.
We have Jared Leto
on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, what movie
does he have coming out?
-He's not talking
about a movie.
He's announcing a world tour
with Thirty Seconds to Mars.
-So he's not talking about
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
coming out
November 17th on Peacock?
-No, he's not talking about it.
-Oh, okay.
-Okay. Who else is on the show?
-AJR is on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
So AJR is going to talk about
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
coming out on peacock.com
November 17th?
You can sign up today.
-Uh, no, AJR is not going to
talk about that at all.
They're a great band,
and they have a new album
coming out tonight --
at midnight, actually.
Tonight. Yeah.
-Wow. So then...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I just don't understand
how the hell anyone
is going to find out about
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
which is coming out, uh,
November 17th on Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I don't know
how that's going to happen.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to let you down.
-Okay. Alright. We're gonna
go do "Seth." Um...
-Wow.
-Before --
Before we leave,
we just want to say
this audience is
the best audience in the world!
-Get out of here!
-Love you, Jimmy.
-Bye, guys.
Get out of here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please Don't Destroy!
Please Don't Destroy.
No one's gonna talk
about it.
The strike is...
[ Laughs ]
That's just so funny.
Guys, anyway, as I was saying,
the strike is finally over.
That's right. When the actors
heard a deal had been reached,
they gasped, screamed,
laughed, cried,
and then were like,
"I also do accents."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, the actors are back
just in time.
I'm not sure the world
could handle another reality
dating show.
Am I right?
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Speaking of --
[ Laughter ]
Like, you recognize
maybe two of those.
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of, tonight was the
"Women Tell All" episode
of "The Golden Bachelor."
-Ooh.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Yeah.
'Cause who doesn't love
hearing their grandma
describe sex?
[ Laughter ]
-Oy!
-"You pulled the muscle
in the fantasy suite?
I pulled a muscle
in the fantasy suite."
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
Starting next month,
Disney+ and Hulu are going
to be merged into the same app.
-Ooh.
-Yep, streamers are merging.
Pretty soon, they're
gonna be all in one
giant app called cable.
[ Laughter ]
What are we doing?
[ Applause ]
What have we done?
-Come on.
-Yep. Disney+ and Hulu
are merging into one app.
That's good.
Now, when your kid tries
to turn on "Bluey," he'll wind
up bingeing "Sons of Anarchy."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, it's good to see you, bud.
I feel like we haven't
caught up in a while.
-Oh, wow.
I'm good.
Thanks for checking in, buddy.
-[ Chuckles ]
What have you been up to lately?
-Not much.
Well, I was in Grand Rapids
the other day.
-Oh. How was that?
Good. Had a little trouble
getting an Uber,
but I figured it out.
-In Grand Rapids
over the weekend,
an Amazon truck was stolen
and then taken on a joy ride.
[ Laughter ]
-What else have
you been up to?
-You know, lots of travel.
Check out this small town
called McKees Rocks.
Just watch cars go by.
It was great.
-Police in McKees Rocks
arrested a man they say
was trying to expose himself
to passing drivers.
[ Laughter ]
-Sounds like you've been busy.
Anything else?
-Let me think.
Um...
Oh, I went to my house
in Connecticut,
just west of Hartford.
Did some gardening -- Oh.
So relaxing.
-In Burlington, Connecticut,
west of Hartford,
a man is now charged
with running
an illegal psychedelic mushroom
growing operation
out of a house.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow. You've had a lot
on your plate.
-Yeah. Also, I went down
to my winter place.
The Villages in Florida.
You know me.
Work hard, play hard.
-A man who lives
in The Villages
was arrested by the feds,
accused of having thousands of
dollars worth of illegal pills
used to treat
erectile dysfunction.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it was nice
catching up with you.
-Hang on.
I'm on the phone with my doctor.
Yeah, well, it's been way
longer than four hours.
-All right, Steve Higgins,
everybody.
Steve.
[ Applause ]
Guys, I heard about
two women in Michigan
who are accused
of embezzling $20,000
from a Girl Scout troop.
-Oh.
-$20,000.
That's almost the amount
your co-worker guilts you
into buying each year.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, one of the women
accused was like, "She did it.
I was just a tagalong."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
♪♪
-Guys, listen to this.
A U.S.-bound flight from London
had to turn around
after crew members realized
that the plane
was missing two windows.
[ Laughter ]
Then they landed
and we were like, "Oh, crap.
We're also missing
two passengers."
[ Laughter ]